un
moment extrêmement difficile je suis
désolé on a le cœur très lourd au sortir
de de cette projection c'est une
atteinte à l'humanité tout entière qui
est la nôtre qu'on a vu dans cette dans
cette salle de projection je pense que
c'était un moment très difficile mais
très nécessaire face à tous les
relativisme et face à tous les risques
d'oubli et je crois que chacun de ceux
qui ont vu cette vidéo ne pourront
plus du moins pendant un long moment
dormir en paix
barbare ces sauvages qui ont de la
jouissance avoir tué des femmes et des
enfants j'ai vu un enfant de 10 ans mais
tuez-moi il a vu son père et sa mère à
tué il a dit tuez-moi pendant qu'ils
ouvraent le frigidaire il prenaent un
cocas zé en train de
boire qui sont dans la dans la
jouissance du massacre c'est ça qui qui
est le plus révoltant et et et et que
certains remettent en cause ce qui s'est
passé et que certains relativise je
trouve ça à vomir voil ça vomir pas du
tout notre rôle comme député c'est de
témoigner de la vérité de ces images et
de dire que dans ce conflit on on n pas
dans une
guerre avec un peuple contre un autre on
est
dans dans un acte terroriste qui est de
détruire l'autre qui le fait avec joie
et qu'il le fait sans que l'autre ne
puisse à aucun moment se se
défendre